hey what's up welcome back to another
episode of visual effects artist react
we are looking at some cool stuff
today if you saw Dune well the director
of that movie made an incredible movie
called a rival it's a really fun one but
there's a lot of really cool invisible
effects in this movie that I really want
to take a look at I'm going to go on a
limb and say that the alien spaceship is
probably digital my nephew Grayson has
submitted his latest blender animation
and well it Bears a striking resemblance
to a movie you may have
seen wow train energy this is so
ridiculous the most extreme meteors and
the prism that Disney holds that heads
the secret to visual effects and the
soul of Walt Disney inside there's a lot
to talk about and unpack from this stuff
you know you're going to really enjoy
this thanks for
[Music]
watching in some of the previous
episodes here we've been looking at the
14-year-old blender animators okay each
time I watch them like I always think
about just how talented they are despite
you know some of the visual shortcomings
you might see in these this next clip
here not only resembles those clips but
also really shows you there's a real
future in doing those train videos let
me show you this here's a future in
train videos
okay W this looks like a previs for a
movie
yeah oh heck yeah wait did he just steer
that
ball look at
this seriously this is a fast and the
fury is fast than the Furious
uh fast the Furious
feas yeah yeah we're watching something
people are spending millions of dollars
on right you tricked us I thought I was
watching a 14-year-old fan film just
really well animated yeah this is previs
for a multi-million dollar franchise wow
look at that there it is you know you
look at the faces in his train video and
then you watch these faces it's like oh
yeah yeah this is like very much the
same skill set it's funny though because
it's like it looks janky but it's also
very much so not janky the animation is
actually really detailed there's
Dynamics going on there's a full
suspension on that car there's like
stuff shattering there's smoke elements
in here there's a whole crowd simulation
people are running around and reacting
like there's so much going on here that
is being conveyed through the previs
here yeah yeah yeah yeah like there's
there's there's a lot going on here
there's a bunch of Polish in the the
cinematography the editing the pacing
like animation is not easy to do
regardless of if you render it with your
you know RTX on or RTX off like but also
the cinematography and like the shot
selection the choices going into this
are very Advanced I would be very
curious to see what the final sequence
looks like in comparison well let's
watch
it it's on fire there it is all these I
mean about half the shots in the
sequence are in the previs okay but it's
less like the previous than I expected
slower yeah they're really taking their
time going down these stairs but that
shots in the Pras yep oh he knocks it
past the lady and the dogs oh they had
that insert shot they don't have yeah
there's more insert shots in this than
the previous you can really get a sense
of like where the editors and the
directors and like feedback is coming
into play where somebody's like oh I
need this beat I can't read this I need
to see this the other the previous
version is just like boom bang boom and
this one is like tons of dialogue and
like reaction shots and insert shots the
previous seems like it's good for
getting everybody on the same page yes
we want kind of that we want that kind
of crazy energy it's like okay let's go
for it because of the rendering quality
it's so far removed from The Fast and
Furious movies and it brought me some
like joy to watch this like really
lowquality janky version of this
expensive action set piece Landon's
cinematography and like action design is
not that far off from like Fast and the
furious's action it really isn't it
really is really pretty
close as you know we mostly work with a
bunch of dudes around here and it has
been a very hot summer so the must has
been kick in this year luckily we've
been armed with three beautiful spelling
colog by today's sponsor s bird s bird
is a fragrance subscription service that
allows you to try a new designer
fragrance or more than one each month
for just $17 we have Vince kudo's home
home we have the handsome Devil's
grooming lounge and we have Joseph ab's
modern gentleman with sun bird you can
sign up and receive up to three travel
cents monthly comes in a nice travel
case that you can pop in your pocket you
just unlock
Spritz m got hints of emesia birch
Cedarwood Cypress and fennel now that we
have all these I'm going to go spice up
the studio and solve this must problem
with scentbird there are over 600
designer Brands to choose from from
designers like Prada Gucci Versace to
Niche Brands like parfumes de Marley and
Confessions of a rebel and many more
smells really good what was that with
each fragrance you get a 30-day Supply
so you can try new fragrances before
committing to the full- size bottle yo
can I get some of
that this $17 subscription is super
valuable because some of these
fragrances cost over50 and some are even
$300 to
$500 hey you saying a
stink
yes do you like it
though I
do Summer's over and the must is gone so
if you want to check out s bird hit that
link in the description or scan the QR
code and use the promo code cordor crew
for 55% off your first month that's only
$8 a month thanks to s for sponsoring
this video now let's get back to the
react so I got a little obscure clip for
you guys like this movie is buried in my
memory somebody mentioned in a comment
and I was just like I don't know it just
stood out to me check this out this is
pretty
neat ooh robots classic I mean the
vibe's great the stuff looks really good
I mean they almost look like they're
practical models at times it's that
stuttery animation on them it gives them
like a sense of realism because we're
familiar with mechanical stuff like
having weight and like chatterin and of
course obviously like the rendering
quality is really good but that's also
relatively
straightforward never mind it was
[Applause]
practical oh well yeah there you go
interesting yeah
interesting knew it yeah called it see I
love this is the sort of thing I love
like it's still a lot of visual effects
going on here but the bulk of what we're
actually seeing in the final thing is
analog we always think visual effects is
like adding something but the ability to
remove something from the frame has like
unlocked so many opportunities for
movies like you can do so many things
everything from like the fact that
wirework is a thing in stunts now to
like puppetry like this a lot of the
time the stuff that they have to paint
out is actually covering part of the
robot so they have to add back in pieces
of the robot that don't actually exist
or maybe they do exist but they're being
added in CG like her uh shins here on
the robot are being added back in it's
still like the majority of that robot is
photo real because it is real so the
small pieces that are CG you already
have something perfect to like match it
to as long as you get get it to the
point that it doesn't draw your eye it
works well it's a guessing game too
you're like okay well I'm seeing these
practical robot legs for 10 shots and
now suddenly we have one shot where
they're not real and you're like I I
would have never known yeah this is the
sort of thing that I think General
audiences can really get behind because
the whole idea that like CGI is a bad
word now you know or it's like no one
likes CGI whereas the truth is that no
one likes bad CGI no one likes CGI that
they notice it's not that CGI is bad and
that using the real practical robots
here is better it's that the end effort
of all of this stuff ends up creating a
better final thing like the actors are
more involved the cinematographer is you
know more on the page of like what the
final shot's going to look like there's
a more tangible feel to it that CGI
sometimes cannot
[Music]
nail wait there's more a few reacts ago
we got to watch some skydiving from
Mission Impossible and then we compared
to skydiving and oh is this from the
beginning of the Power Rangers movie no
oh so in the world of crazy cool stunts
like in Point Break and like pretty well
executed CGI let's be real in Mission
Impossible lies a world in the Middle
with crazy stunts and really not good
VFX oh yeah baby wait what what a
[Music]
rip yeah all the close-up shots are
obviously filmed on like a blue screen
but those first few weren't that bad
like that's not that bad that one where
okay okay that's a crazy stunt oh my God
that's that was real and then it cut to
that light wrap
City I'm kidding
him yes sick all sweet so sweet what a
boss shot I know right I know it's Super
Rad unhooking your parachute and then
back flipping into like the most like
powerful pose this pose I need maximum
speed maximum speed maximum speed like
seriously is there a faster posture this
is what I'm noticing on that shot here
it's that it's very obviously Studio
lighting yeah not only is the light not
changing as the background's spinning
around it's like coming from different
directions like he's nicely Edge lit
he's lit from the front he's got all
these different highlights on him and
it's like no he should be lit by the sun
you guys want to know how this movie
ends this movie is about Wesley Snipes
taking down a gang of techn terrorist
skydivers at the IRS oh so we those were
the bad guys in the beginning I think
so
yeah wait was that a cut did you see a
cut oh wait a minute what a
shot dummy dummy I love
dummies he's doing the same move wait
[Laughter]
what so the the close-ups on Wesley
Snipes and Bucy are kind of rough yeah
the the actual like yeah the or the you
know the key scenes here the background
is like really crunched and I don't know
if that's like a like a processing issue
like they didn't know how to handle
gamma back then but like the gamma on
the background plate honestly the whole
plate is super crushed yeah cuz like
this is the era of having to scan film
in work with it in the computer and then
print it back on to film was this before
Mario Brothers this is like at the same
time as Mario Brothers so this is they
they are it's like the Russians trying
to land on the moon it's a competition
yes but little did I mean history has
told us the story in Mario 1 yeah so ilm
was like the only company that could
print digital effects back onto film
they had all the actual like Optical
printers and in the early '90s Finly
other companies were starting to get
into that game but they hadn't quite
fully cracked what happens to colors
when you take it from a piece of film
into a computer doesn't look the same
you can't just scan it in with a you
know a regular RGB color values doesn't
quite look right and then you work out
in the computer once it you make it look
correct he Tred to print that back on
the film but it doesn't look like it did
on your computer screen what the heck so
there's this whole color science step
that like like required you know experts
and scientists to like go in and figure
it out and if you didn't quite get it
100% right it looks kind of like this
what's crazy to me is there's a real guy
it's crazy that tackled a dummy through
a glass window without any wires and he
just had a parachute and he did this for
real it's like oh that's so rad hey
normally we tell you to subscribe moving
on so I wanted to look at some of the
effects from the movie arrival back in
the day before Den villanu got all sandy
he was making Alien movies what I found
really impressive about this movie was
the subtlety of it all so let's just
take a
look what an epic shot to begin on with
the clouds coming down over the hill
like that was that actually captured
that's real plate photography here like
those clouds doing that is actually real
that's so cool that's like my favorite
like natural effect Earth's coolest
practical effect
clouds that go down but like there's
this whole encampment here right of like
these military tents and these
helicopters and satellite dishes so what
do you think of all that stuff is real
versus digital I'm going to go out on
limb and say that the alien spaceship is
probably digital and the camp probably
is as well in its entirety yeah I have
to say so well all the buildings are
real really yeah so a company called
oblique effects actually did most of the
exterior shots and Landscapes mat
paintings for this movie the buildings
are all real but the people they're
dropping in and the helicopters they're
dropping in any sort of military
vehicles there's no reason to do that
for real because they're hard surface
models it's actually pretty easy these
days to do tanks helicopters and just do
all that CG come
on I think and then when they actually
go up into the ship gravity changes and
so that introduces a unique problem for
transitioning in there but everything
we're seeing has been CG wait really the
character models are all CG CG yeah so
this is a fully CG shot here that's
crazy what they did was they filmed with
these helmets around their head that are
lighting up their faces the only thing
real that we're seeing here is just the
faces but those faces are inside of the
CG render of the whole hazmat suit on
top of it why does this work so dang
well really unique directional
lighting I found this to be really
interesting so they actually did a wire
stunt where they get pulled backwards
but look at that did you notice it yes
they're on a blue screen but the thing
that they're actually directly in front
of is another giant white screen and
that gives them natural realistic light
wrap and it's it's a relatively easy
effect to do in post but when you can
actually nail it optically it looks
pretty good I mean when you do it in
post I think it looks like total booty
the thing is you can't just light wrap
everything which people will do if they
want to blend stuff it's like oh it's
not quite blending well just just light
wrap everything but only the really
bright stuff should have any sort of
wrap and that wrap is really happening
on the lens side of the camera it's not
happening in real life I've never done
it I have never just intentionally
turned on a giant light behind someone
with the intention of cutting them out
later yeah all around just everything's
great man Deni has just like been doing
hit after hit he did this then he did
Blade Runner then he did Dune now he's
doing Dune 2 hey Deni if you see this
episode you want to join us on the couch
for our director's react it would be
quite an
honor a trouble where no man has dared
to go so there's a movie that came out
called the black hole 1979 and for a lot
of people this was the thing after Star
Wars that was like the big sci-fi film
this is a Disney movie when David goer
was on the show he mentioned he was a
big fan of this movie so I want to do
some research on it we didn't end up
looking at it but there's this one shot
it's pretty Bonkers shot and yeah let's
take a
look ah that 70s aesthetic interesting
wait a
minute my I my
my wow wait that was very very good
yeah isn't that a good shot that was
sweet so what I think this is is that
we're seeing a miniature maybe the whole
set is actually vertical and the
camera's pointed upwards so that this
thing can like fall down but then we're
also seeing tiny people running across a
bridge that are comped into this shot
and in the same shot that we see the
Bridge get destroyed looks really good
yeah but you it's funny when the thing
hits the bridge you can see the mat line
oh you're right what the heck now this
shot is crazy I don't know how they did
that shot you think they used the prism
for this shot no I think this is another
comp shot yeah I think you're right I
think it is a comp shot I don't think
it's real projection I feel like they
probably used the prism people are
probably wondering what the heck are you
talking about this prism so Disney
invented this way of filming so instead
of a green screen it was like an orange
screen it was a very specific band of
light frequency that they would light
with like sodium vapor and they had a
prism that would split off just that one
frequency of light and all the rest of
the light would go to the other
direction so they'd expose one piece of
film with just the sodium vapor light
then another piece of film with all the
rest of the light and basically they got
a live Alpha Channel a perfect green
screen but did they ever actually use it
after Mar Poppins yes all the time
really I mean how many other movies did
they use it on the process was used in
the 1970s for scenes in Island at the
top of the world The Apple Dumpling Gang
bed knobs and Broomsticks Freaky Friday
Escape to Witch Mountain Pete's
Dragon and the black
hole they used the prism it's just crazy
to me that you don't have any color
limitations you can wear green you can
wear blue you have semi- trans parent
lace like they did Mary po which is
mindblowing yeah there's no information
out there on this I would love to get in
contact with whoever has this prism
still just so we can take a look at it
like this is this is part of film
history and Disney's got it in the
vaults some say Walt Disney's Souls
trapped inside
it a
soul soul specifically a soul gam there
that'll be it though that will be the
that'll be the final episode of the show
by the way like you tell is is VFX
artists react to Disney's sacred
prism and it just start going oh we got
to find that prison man we got to find
that prison we got we got to find that
pris help us find the pris leave a
comment as where we can find the prism
you know just just help get us started
yeah what do you think it is Maps if you
got them let us know oh you know you can
also tell us your favorite prism visual
effect shot you could react to them in
the prism episode when inevitably gets
filmed actually that's a great idea let
us know what's your favorite prism shot
you know we try to talk about visual
effects but every once in a while we go
off the rails a little bit and get a
little spicy get a little goofy get a
little unhinged if you want to check it
out go to Gard digital.com as we do the
extended episodes I guess we got to call
them the unhinged versions now
unhinged